you guys are just getting started
you're not gonna start right here
you're gonna start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development it is vital it was
vital for me that i improved myself and
i could start depending upon me i had to
show up every day with some rituals some
disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning
i'm going to beat that sun up every
morning so that i have the discipline
and the control over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops i'm
gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment when i
was younger between 15 and 25 i was
doing crazy stuff in my life wasting my
weekends i have the same weekends are
for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick-start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was gonna do
that i woke up when i said i would wake
up and i start building respect for
myself start believing in myself so that
i can go out into the world and maybe
maybe maybe today maybe today when i go
into this meeting that i'm dressed for
maybe they'll believe in me as much as i
believe in me and that'll show up in a
contract a deal maybe even some money as
mark twain said
[Music]
the secret to getting ahead
is getting started
that's something i want all of you guys
to really embody and really think about
really put at the core of your existence
that step number one to accomplishing
whatever it is that you want to do is
actually getting started and i
understand i know the thing that holds
you back i know the thing that is
absolutely
paralyzing for people
is you don't think that you have what it
takes to go out and be good and rather
than face that difficult brutal process
of growing and getting better and quite
frankly facing your inadequacies
it's easier just to sit back but as john
wooden said never let what you cannot do
interfere with what you can there is
something right now that you're capable
of there is an innate skill inside of
you that's your spark it's that starting
point it's that thing that while you may
not be the best in the world at it it's
a flame that you can fan it's something
that you can breathe life into and
really begin to get good but first you
have to understand the very nature of
progress
and that's as stephen covey said
you're not the product of your
circumstances but rather a product of
your decisions and it's those decisions
that are going to allow you to build
that skill sets don't worry about where
you started don't worry about what you
already have remember it's the decisions
that you make it's going down that road
it is
the decision
to get started it's the decision to face
possible failure it's the decision to
get up once you failed and it's the
decision
of what to learn when you fail
do you learn that you're not good enough
do you learn you never should have tried
or do you learn a lesson from the
failure and get up and brush yourself
off and remember that at the end of the
day
you're going to go as far as you're
willing to fight for and that's it if
you're willing to fight to go all the
way then you will go that far you will
set a new bar you will define for people
what
is possible
you become that beacon of hope you
become that thing that other people look
to as the standard
but at the end of the day it started
with you getting started it started with
you showing up it started with you
pushing and trying
so get out there
don't worry about
what you have and what you are
focus on who you want to become
and the price you're willing to pay to
get there i believe in a higher power
don't know the name don't know where
it's coming from don't anything like
that but i believe that
this power
and visualizing real quick
let's say it's a man up there or a woman
whatever and they have a chart and when
you're born
they say david goggins
born february 17th 1975 at 6 00 a.m
they write the chart down because they
can see everything they know exactly
where you're supposed to be
they know where you're supposed to be
you die you go to so-called heaven
you arrive at heaven i'm 300 pounds i
retired as an ecolab guy which is okay
just a job whatever
i go up there and god
looks at me and he shows me my chart
and my chart on there says you were
supposed to be a navy seal
you're supposed to weigh 185 pounds
you're supposed to be one of the
smartest people on the planet this this
all this you see this and now you're in
heaven you're made to heaven but you're
like god i was supposed to live that
life
i was supposed to live that life and
then you find out that the reason why
because we all think that if we pray on
it if we do this if we do that whatever
if we don't work we just whatever this
could magically happen for us
no
i believe that when i'm all said and
done with my whole job is to outwork the
chart
whatever the chart says about me the
all-knowing power up there i want to get
up there and say him look at me and say
i know everything
i didn't
see this
i want to feel that i want to get to the
other end of this
world
and however i'm being judged
whoever's judging me to look at me and
say i did not
no i had you at 185 had you that this
but all this other i was riding as you
were living it
i want to
i want to find more
all i can
and in that
sack of
you have to dive in that
to find more
because if you're not willing to go in
there and face yourself
you're not going to find anything
you're going to live right here on
surface man right here on surface
so there is an ending to this world and
there is somewhere to go and there's a
judgment
you're going to get there and you might
see a chart
and that chart may tell you who the f
you should have been
and now you get to rest your life to
think about that man i could have lived
a much better life if i just
would have just suffered a little bit
more i always thought procrastination
had to do with the thing i was
procrastinating around right like that
procrastination has something to do with
work
believe it or not procrastination has
nothing to do with your work
procrastination is a form of stress
relief let me explain this
so let's say that you've got some stuff
going on in your life and heck who
doesn't have stuff going on in your life
maybe you're fighting with your
significant other maybe mom's or dad's
health is failing and it's really really
upsetting you maybe you've got some
financial stuff you put too much of your
savings into bitcoin and now that that's
crashed you're stressed out about it
right and so you go into work and when
you get into work you got stuff to do
you kind of walk in and you got this big
stress ball that uh subconsciously is
hanging over your head and so you walk
in and you sit down and you know you got
13 phone calls you need to make and you
also know that you've been chickening
out you've been making easy calls and
there's a bunch of cios or other people
that are higher level that you haven't
been calling and so as you sit down to
do it you got the stress on your
shoulders your brain
that it starts to go wait a minute you
want me to make a call to somebody that
i'm scared to make absolutely not i'm so
stressed out about can we just watch
some cat videos for a minute
and next thing you know an hour's gone
by and then of course what do you do you
beat yourself up so the only way that
you can break this habit
and that's an important word for you to
hear
you're not a procrastinator
you have a habit
of procrastinating
big difference
because if it's a habit i can teach you
to use science to break it
you see all habits have three parts
there's a trigger and in the case of
procrastination the trigger is always
stress then there's a pattern you repeat
and in the case of procrastination it is
to avoid doing something and then
there's a reward you get a little stress
relief the only way to break a habit you
guys is not to deal with the triggers
you're never going to get rid of the
stress in your life but you can 100
change your pattern of avoiding work
so next time that you're in a situation
where you feel yourself hesitate you
spent way too much time checking out the
highlights from last night's scores what
you're going to do is you're going to go
up i must be stressed out about
something acknowledge the stress then go
5-4-3-2-1
i want you to count yourself because i
want you to interrupt the habit that's
stored here and i want you to awaken
your prefrontal cortex then i want you
to just work just for five minutes the
reason why i want you to only work for
five minutes is because your problem
isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding
i just need you to start and here's the
other cool thing
we know based on research that if we can
get you to start 80 of you are going to
keep going many years ago
i was asked a very interesting question
somebody asked me a question they raised
their hand in the seminar and said
tony
can you change people that don't want to
change
of course you can change people don't
want to change
all you need is the right kind of
if you have enough leverage where change
becomes an absolute
now for some people
leverage is not even the threat of their
own life
some people rather die
than have you tell them what to do
and so that's not the leverage
the leverage for them might be
something for their children
leverage for them might be spiritual
growth
all of us have a leverage point
if you find the leverage not the
leverage you make someone do it the
leverage that will make them make
themselves do it
we all have some place
that'll get us to follow through
now if you get enough leverage and if
you interrupt the pattern enough how
many of you ever had a pattern when you
were a kid
and you had like some obnoxious uncle or
something
and you were trying to be upset and
they'd come like rub your damn head or
something i should make you crazy
and you couldn't stay upset because they
kept doing this to you how many how does
this happen say aye
if you have enough leverage and you
break someone's pattern enough times
a new pattern will show up
if you're conscious you can create the
new pattern
so the answer is yes now then the
question would be tony
if all it takes is leverage
then why don't most people change
and i had a lot of answers to that but
that night i'm a night person
that night i'm wired up after a seminar
it's like two o'clock in the morning it
was december
and so i flip on the television in the
back for some white noise looking for
cnn and i come across the old
christmas classic
this christmas carol right a dickens
classic
and i see it in black and white and i
start watching the movie and remembering
it for being a kid
and as i'm watching this thing
i see this man named scrooge
who clearly doesn't want to change
in fact he's certain he doesn't need to
change
because what's happened is his life went
through a lot of pain
and when he got pain he looked for the
source of that pain and he said it was
being close to people
so we decided his people equals pain
remember the red squares we talked about
so now he wants to avoid people
and he's mean to people
now he's also very wealthy financially
he makes up this belief that because i'm
mean and tough with people i'm rich
the truth is he's financially rich if
you watch the movie you read the story
when everyone else is gone who's still
working
he is
he's hard-working he's thrifty smart
he's intelligent but he thinks he's rich
because he's mean so he doesn't want to
lose being rich he doesn't want to lose
not being hurt
so he has a belief be mean to people and
everything works out
even though he's miserable can we have
beliefs that make no sense
and yet still believe them yes or no
sure we just get wired
so i'm watching this guy
now the only way people change
is if they associate either enough what
pain so they have to change or they
associate changing will equal enough
what
and ideally if you get both you'll
change
if you get
every moment i do this the pain is
getting more and more intense there's a
point where you must change
and if you get if i change i get all
this pleasure you're going to want to
change
how many follow
but what equals pain and what equals
pleasure
is what you associate in your nervous
system
so what happens is
the only way you create change
is changing what you link pain
and what you link pleasure to in your
nervous system not just in your head
in your gut
that's what controls you lots of times
in your head you know what you should do
but your gut takes over your fear
or your greed or your desire or your
comfort or whatever who knows what i'm
talking about here say i
but watch this
how many of you used to have a favorite
dessert
or a food
or a form of alcohol
that you really really really loved
and then one night you had an experience
like never before
where something happened
where this food of this drink and this
alcohol that you love so much
it went down
but it kept coming back up
at a level of intensity and with enough
aroma
and pain and association
that to this day
it takes no willpower just to think of
that alcohol or think of the smell of
that food or look at it makes you
appalled makes you repelled who's had an
experience like this in your life say i
tell me what that change was was that a
change in willpower
no all that happened is
your brain changed what it used to link
pleasure to it now link pain to
when you lick enough pain it takes no
willpower you're going to avoid it the
problem is some of you linking pain to
things you need
like exercise
right or pain what you need
like
a relationship
right and it's the wrong association but
it's gonna control your life
your job is to change what you link pain
and pleasure to so that night what was
pleasure became pain and now it takes no
willpower you just avoid it
so we call that changing what you
associate the things in your nervous
system or for short a neural associative
change in other words changing in your
neuro your nervous system what you
associate pain and pleasure to
so by the way in this christmas carol
story does this man scrooge change his
life yes or no
he didn't want to change
does he change his life a little or
completely
and by the way how fast
that heartbeat one evening how does it
happen three
neuroassociative conditioning
specialists show up at his house
right three ghosts show up and what do
they do they get him to link a massive
unbearable amount of what
to all the things he did in the past
around people then they go to everything
he has in the present pain everything in
the future pain till there's so much
there was no word escape here's the
other reason why people don't change
because right now my relationships in
pain
but
it was good in the past
so you escape having to change by
remembering a good time
or
i might be coughing and having these
problems with cigarettes right now
but you know what george burns lived to
be 102.
he smokes cigars by the way and
he's one out of 10 billion people that
pulled that off
but let's not confuse ourselves with
ratios
so you make up what the future is if
your present is painful you can escape
to the past and get out of the pressure
to change how many followers say i
or you can escape to a future because no
one knows what it is for sure and you
can make it up
but if your brain links it's been
painful in the what
past in the
it's even worse in the you'll change
like that
who here has ever stayed in a
relationship
that you knew was not right for you it
wasn't right for you it wasn't right for
them who has ever stayed in a
relationship way too long who's done
this before raise your hand say i it
wasn't good for you wasn't good for them
yet you stayed why
why
because even though it's painful in the
present what'd you do you said it'll get
better over there in the future
why who finally changed who here finally
changed that say i
how'd you do it your brain went it's
painful now it was painful in the past
it's gonna be worse in the future that's
it
that's what i call a dickens pattern
when you lock in pain in all those
places there's no place to escape so you
change it's like if you put a wall here
a wall here and a wall here and we close
him in on you amazingly you'll move
forward
that's what we're talking about giving
yourself leverage on yourself that way
not having someone else do to you you do
it to yourself that's when you got the
power again every morning
in seal training
my instructors who at the time were all
vietnam veterans
would show up in my barracks room
and the first thing they'd do is inspect
my bed
if you did it right
the corners would be square the covers
would be pulled tight the pillow
centered just under the headboard and
the extra blanket folded neatly at the
foot of the rack
it was a simple task
mundane at best but every morning
we were required
to make our bed to perfection
it seemed a little ridiculous at the
time particularly in light of the fact
that we were aspiring to be real
warriors tough battle-hardened seals
but the wisdom of this simple act
has been proven to me many times over
if you make your bed every morning
you will have accomplished the first
task of the day
it will give you a small sense of pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task
and another and another
and by the end of the day that one task
completed will have turned into many
tasks completed
making your bed will also reinforce the
fact
that the little things in life matter
if you can't do the little things right
you'll never be able to do the big
things right
and if by chance you have a miserable
day
you will come home to a bed that is made
that you made
and a made bed gives you encouragement
that tomorrow will be better
so if you want to change the world
start off by making your bed the hardest
part about failing
that people battle with is not
necessarily the failures the emotion
attached to the failure
because we we come from
human beings are
uh social creatures
so that's why you live with your family
you don't live alone
that's why you live in a society and a
community that's why you go to a church
that's why you go to an office and
everywhere you go
when you get there there are other human
beings
human beings are social creatures
and a part of being a social creature is
it is feedback
so
you have the friends you have because
you like the feedback when you make a
joke they laugh
um you
you go to the places you go to because
you like the feedback so as human beings
were in a constant system of feedback
when you went to school
at the end of a term you wrote a test or
an exam for feedback
[Music]
the hardest part about failing
is you don't like the feedback
because because
you don't know
if you failed or if the business failed
because you are the business you're the
entrepreneur
and so you you have to deal with these
emotions attached to failure
and then what happens is you start
questioning yourself you start asking
questions like
am i really as good as i think i am
like
am i really this good or has it just
been my ego this whole time
and then you go back to the time when
there was a guy in high school who told
you you'd be up you'd amount to nothing
or an ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend who
told you that you would amount to
nothing and you maybe they were right
you know what's funny about human beings
is if you wrote a test
and you got 70
[Music]
your mind doesn't see them the answers
you've got right
when you go through the exam paper after
you get it back from your teacher you
look for the answers you got wrong
because that's how we're wired as human
beings
so if
you
have had a hundred people tell you
you're amazing
and three people tell you you are
useless
you will always remember the three
people
it's what i call it's what's called the
imposter syndrome so your internal
dialogue starts being framed by
negative perceptions of self by self
based on the perceptions of others
so the real problem with failure
is because
it it supports
the three people who told you you're
worth nothing
not the 97 who told you you're amazing
so for me that was like the hardest part
right like the hardest part was going
the hardest part was having to
understand that i was not that failure
that the failure didn't define me that
it was it was a moment you know it was
it happened
and um
you know and i needed to move on from it
um
and that failing doesn't make you any
less
of what you were you're still great
you're still amazing you're still
smart and intelligent and hard-working
you're still all of those things all of
those things about you are true
the event
does not define you it's just an event
you're an athlete that showed up to run
100 meter race and had a bad race
doesn't mean you're a bad athlete you
had a bad race
lack of consistency is one of the
biggest reasons why entrepreneurs fail
one of the biggest reasons you're a
genius you have great ideas you want to
serve you know you're capable of more
and you have these moments of
inspiration and moments of boldness and
moments of massive productivity and
focus and clarity but it's not
consistent
and that's why most entrepreneurs will
lose
because you might crush it on a saturday
or sunday or monday but then tuesday
wednesday thursday friday you fall back
down until the next saturday when you're
up and flying again it's not enough it's
much more about what you do every day
you are what you consistently do it's a
huge problem for entrepreneurs so let's
fix them number one if you are a
part-time entrepreneur if you work for
someone else you're part-time
entrepreneur you need to make sure that
every single day you're working on your
business every single day you have to
work on your business no matter what
even if it's for 15 minutes at night
every single day you cannot let momentum
die even just to show yourself that you
can't even if it's a crazy long day and
your boss is yelling at you and you come
home and your spouse is angry and your
kids are even then
you have to spend 15 minutes on your
business half an hour in your business
every single day you cannot let the
momentum die don't disappoint yourself
number two if you're already full time
in your business great you need to have
ceo time every day in your business ceo
time time where you spend being the ceo
what does that mean it's different for
different entrepreneurs but when you're
working on the business instead of in it
if you spend all time
just working in the business just
putting out fires and never growing
guess what you're never gonna grow if
you never have ceo time built into your
business you will never be a ceo and so
you need to make sure that every day you
have ceo time built into your business
again maybe it's only half an hour but
in that half an hour you're spending
time growing your company you're gonna
start seeing results and my last tip is
i want you to start your morning off
powerfully i want you to chart your
start i want you to have a morning
routine that inspires you that makes you
feel bold most people what do they do
when they wake up first thing they do is
they hit the snooze button what does
that mean it means last night you set a
goal i'm going to wake up at a certain
time right i'm going to wake up at 6 a.m
5 a.m 7 00 am 12 00 noon i don't care
what time you have to wake up you set a
goal you're gonna wake up and then the
very first thing that you do how you
start your day every day you say i am
not going to hit my goal today that's
how you start your day that's how most
of america starts her day they say i'm
not going to hit my goal today how do
you think you're going to go off and
have an amazing day and crush it and go
hit your crazy big goals and ambitions
that you have as an entrepreneur when
you tell yourself and you reinforce it
every morning that you are the kind of
person who doesn't hit their goals you
got to change that you got to wake up
wake up when you say you're going to
wake up get out of bed when you say
you're going to get out of bed that's
step one then step two is what is a
morning routine that sets you up for
success most people wake up like it's an
accident they wake up you check your
phone you're responding to other
people's emergencies and their agenda
for your time
that's not how you need to start your
day successful people they own their
morning what does your morning look like
and we've all felt inspired and bold at
some point you felt it you've been bold
been inspired at some point in your life
great whatever that thing was it made
you feel bold unstoppable inspired put
that into your morning routine maybe
just watching a video maybe it's reading
the book maybe it's doing an act of
kindness maybe it's meditating maybe
it's prayer whatever it is with
intention because some of you have a
morning routine already i'm talking to
you you have a morning routine already
but you're not crushing it every day
you're not coming out of that morning
routine feeling bold inspired
consistently that's what we're talking
about consistency here
sometimes you just go through the
motions of your morning routine
sometimes you just pray but you're not
really connecting sometimes you just
watch a video but you're making your
breakfast you're brushing your teeth and
you're not paying attention with
intention to your morning routine you
must come out of your morning routine
every single day feeling bold
unstoppable and confident if you did
that if you woke up every day on time
like you say you're going to you're not
getting the snooze button you get out of
bed and then you did the thing that made
you feel bold powerful and unstoppable
every single day holy cow i guarantee
you your life one year from today will
look dramatically different than where
you are right now consistency is the
game you are what you consistently do
and i want to see you win
the more you live your life based on
what other people think of it you're
going to lose
you're going to lose listen you're an
entrepreneur you want to do crazy things
you you have a bold ambitious vision for
what you want to accomplish in your life
you want to change the way something's
done in the industry right that's what
we want to do we want to change the
world you know what there's a lot of
people who want to protect the world the
status quo they want to protect the way
things are done you want to come in and
shake up an industry there's a lot of
people who want to protect that industry
there's a lot of people who don't like
change there's a lot of people who are
so afraid of seeing you be successful
because it means that they suck right
there's a lot of people who who are in
your environment in your family in your
home your friends people who they don't
want to see you win because it means
they suck because you've left them
because it means that they're not good
anymore because they judge themselves
based off of what everybody else is
doing and a lot of people have someone
in their family who went off and crushed
it and they tried it and then they
failed right they tried it they may have
had some success and then they failed
and now nobody else around them is
allowed to be successful
all they want to do is pull everybody
else down they took their shot
ultimately didn't work you know they
pull everybody else around them you
can't let that be you the more you want
to go off and have a bold ambitious life
for yourself the more you're going to
have to learn to what i call inoculate
yourself against judgment you need to
inoculate yourself against judgment the
judgment of your friends your parents
the people around you the general public
social media inoculate yourself against
judgment as long as you care what other
people think of you you will lose you
will play small forever you will not be
living your version of your life and so
how do you do it how do you inoculate
yourself against judgment here's how it
goes anytime you feel your heart beating
boom boom boom boom boom boom your
heart's beating you're nervous you're
scared you're worried about what
someone's gonna think of you you have to
do the thing you train yourself even if
it's not an expression of you even if
you don't really care about doing that
thing or not you have to do it just to
train yourself
something like this would have been
really difficult for me 10 years ago
filming on the street was really hard
i'd be worried about what people think
of me be worried about me standing here
san francisco people walking by what
they think of me yelling into my phone
yelling into this microphone here
talking to you guys right here it's
scary and so because
this potential judgment you get scared
and then you don't do the thing teach
yourself to do the thing if filming in
public sounds like a scary thing to you
like oh i couldn't do that go do it go
find the busiest street that you can
find and then go make a video and here's
the thing expect it to suck you're not
going to be great the first time you do
something that's okay expect to suck
expect it to be the worst video you've
ever made and then pat yourself on the
back and say i didn't the first thing
most people do have to make a decision
is they plan they strategize they tinker
they think and it's the worst thing you
can do here's why you make a bold
decision you say i'm going to change my
life i'm going to go off and do this
crazy amazing thing and then you go home
and you think of all the ways that you
can happen and you start planning and
strategizing is amazing you feel great
and then you wake up tomorrow and you're
a different person you wake up tomorrow
a different person and that person said
you can't do that
you can't follow through on that who are
you to take on that big idea and then
nothing happens
nothing happens and so the solution
after you get immediate idea is action
don't worry about planning
even imperfect action just action
because you need to build it into your
nervous system that you're the kind of
person who follows through because you
need to make some commitment so that by
the time you wake up tomorrow you've
committed the following through that's
the biggest problem i call the two
percent difference so what most people
will do is they'll plan to 100 you get
an idea you got a plan you got to go
home you got a plan plan plan plan you
got to plan all the way to the end and
it's amazing and you think about it it's
such a great place to live in as
entrepreneurs as perfectionists as over
planners we love living in that world
don't worry about planning to 100
percent instead find the two percent
difference what can you do right now to
get two percent of the way if you don't
get two percent of the way immediately
to action you will never get to 100 of
the way you have to fight to reach your
dream
you have to sacrifice and work hard for
it
that's coming from the man who has come
to define natural talent
but that's what other people put on him
people want to see somebody who's just
naturally talented it's god-given they
were graced they were blessed with
something at birth
but what does he say when he's asked
about what it took to become the person
that he is
it took hard work it took sacrifice it
took giving things up it took doubling
down it took pushing himself every day
day after day and that's the thing about
hard work
when you put that kind of unending
blinding effort into something it gets
to the point where you've worked so hard
that it looks like magic that people
would sooner believe that it's dna that
it's gifted that it is god-given than to
believe
that they would have to work that hard
to replicate it but if you can stop
making other people extraordinary as a
way to let yourself off the hook then
you too can become extraordinary all of
us are capable of far more than we think
we're capable of more than the people
who love us the most think we are
capable of more than the people who hate
us the most would have us believe
at the end of the day
it is a very simple question you're
going to have to ask yourself
and answer for yourself
how hard are you willing to work
how much are you willing to sacrifice
but on the other side of that is power
and energy and as kyle rhode jr said if
you're attacking you don't get as tired
as when you're chasing
and that's the key
when you
know what you want and when you will not
be held back from getting it suddenly
you go on the offensive it's not about
pleasing somebody else it's not about
chasing somebody else becoming them or
even beating them it is about yourself
knowing what you want and attacking it
going after it and not letting anybody
dissuade you it is looking at yourself
and recognizing how you have to improve
to get that good but you've got to
hunger for that goal you've got to
hunger to get across and win you've got
to want that
the way that a man whose head is on fire
wants a pond
and when you get to that stage when
you're able to cultivate something in
yourself like that something that is
refusing to be extinguished something
that will be heard something that will
stand up and be counted
then you're going to have what you need
to get the skills that you need to move
forward to win to attack and in that
attack and having the energy to move
forward relentlessly
you will find that even though you're
working harder than you've ever worked
in your life
you're more energized than you've ever
been in your life
the times where you fatigue
they're not the times you're working the
hardest
the times you fatigue are when you're
being leased yourself you're not being
true to who you are and what you want
so right now
right now
start being honest about what it is
you're willing to attack
start being honest about who you want to
be what you're willing to become and the
price you're willing to pay to get there
if you give yourself over to that
you will not be able to be stopped these
thoughts that we have we think there are
thoughts so it makes it really hard to
change them and people meditate try to
not think thoughts
show me some of your thumbnails
successfully consistently if they're
full
everybody the mind thinks thoughts but
here's the distinction
if i told you a hundred years ago we're
gonna fly to the moon and back you would
call me a lunatic that's where the charm
comes from people still use it and it
doesn't make any sense because the
lunatic is somebody thought we got the
moon back we've done it right
i didn't know that yeah
that's where it comes from but if i
would have told you 100 years ago that
there's going to be a box in your pocket
and you're going to pull this thing out
you're going to hit a couple buttons and
then it's going to capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're going
to see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're going to talk to them
you're totally nuts
thoughts are those invisible waves
and when you use your body in a certain
way if i sit like this i'm going to
channel i'm going to tap into a
different channel of those waves than if
i'm sitting like this
kind of like a tv set if i turn one
channel it might be a comedy channel i'm
gonna see a lot of laughter turn another
one it's a horror channel turn another
channel it's a romance channel
this is what changes which of those
waves you touch in so if you can start
to realize that your thoughts do you
think are your thoughts there's nothing
unique about your thoughts they've been
around for thousands of years you're
just tapping into them because of what
you're doing with your body that makes
you either fearful or passionate or
courageous or whatever you're feeling as
you go in those states you get different
thoughts so what i want people to see is
that learn how to just see those
thoughts go by learn how to be
entertained by those thoughts because i
have crazy thoughts and but what i've
gotten good at is going look at that
crazy thought that's not me that's the
mind not your mind because if it's you
how do you change you pretty hard
but i really truly know there's i
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them they've been
around forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and then again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better and better and all of a sudden
they used to make you crazy or stressed
out and like how many things have you
worried about that never came to be and
some people their life is good so they
worry about other people you know so
they're never not worried right so it's
really just a pattern if you want wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion
it's like what are we really after in
money you don't want money you want
pieces of paper with the pictures the
deceased notables on it you want what
you think money will give you think
it'll give you freedom or security or
stability or love it won't give you love
it'll get you sex it won't get you a lot
of money won't right so
really what you're after is the emotion
and so what i want people to get is the
emotion they want now and all it is is a
new habit it's learning to discipline
this mind
right by realizing the mind thoughts are
out there
and letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can i love about
this what can i appreciate it's like if
you can learn to love or at least
appreciate
start to enjoy
the things that you used to get upset
about
how much freedom would you have how much
more joy you have and i know people got
billions of dollars i've coached them
who was like holy [__] they live in
scarcity all the time one man i'll never
forget he's screaming at his wife i'm in
the media i mean i'm in the house and
he's screaming at his wife because she
spent some money on a bunch of outfits
and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughter's in her
20s who spent some money too and i'm
like i pulled him aside afterwards and i
said
what do you do this for
and what are you doing for and he's like
well it's just it's the principal thing
i said no the principle thing is do you
love these people and do you want them
to have an abundant life
when you have there's you don't have one
loss but you live like you're poor
you know and it's like i finally got
through them but so many people that's
why i say money doesn't change you money
magnifies who you are so you want to
expand the depth of who you are and free
yourself from suffering by just knowing
it's a pattern of thought and you can
change the pattern of thought you got to
commit first when you know something's
right folks commit
commit
go all in on the deal nobody knows what
you're what you're up to nobody knows
what's going on inside me i called my
mom that night and i said i met my wife
today and she's like
have you all been out where did y'all go
what did you do i said no she hates me
and she's like she hates you grant it
takes two and this is what i knew from
being in business and if you're taking
notes it might be worthwhile it does not
take two to tango
it does not take two to make a marriage
and it does not take a buyer and a
seller what it takes is you
it needs to be you first you have to
decide they're selling a house and you
got to decide that they're buying the
house before any house makes a
transaction i had to decide that she was
going to be the girl before she could
see that i was going to be the guy you
guys with me
all right 26 phone calls all of them
were like hey how you doing you know i
didn't mention that she never calls me
back
i didn't mention that she was breaking
my heart every time she didn't call me i
didn't mention the fact that her best
friend said i was too short
okay
you guys know what all your objections
are don't you like her friend said
you're too short i said just tell me
what the real deal is i got to know what
the objection is i cannot handle the
unspoken objection what is the real deal
grant you're too sharp i said okay what
else what else you got uh you're not a
hollywood guy she's she's an actress i
wasn't in hollywood i'm not an actor
okay good what else you're a businessman
she thinks you're too conservative okay
what else what else you got well you
don't have a prison record
you don't have a prison record no
tattoos she like bad boys okay how many
ladies here like the bad boys
just be honest
okay be honest lady over here is like
yes
i love them okay so so i just continue
to pursue her because like somebody said
earlier sometimes people change
how many of your room have changed
exactly you're going to keep changing
too some of you you're not going to like
so so
i pursued her until one day because i
know this okay and you might want to
keep this in your collection of
how you handle uh discouragement along
the way
when you get a no would you agree that
no is a version of yes
how many would agree with that
dude look i mean think about it what's
the opposite of
what's the opposite of no
what's in between
maybe
so i always tell people when they tell
me no i'm like don't say no
say maybe
okay just say maybe oh well maybe grant
maybe but not right now excellent
because i know no's can turn into yeses
i said no to a lot of things in life and
then done them you've walked into a
casino before i am not gambling tonight
i will not gamble you came down to cabo
i am not drinking while i'm here
okay you some of you came down no
enriched bread while i'm here
no chips no guacamole nothing okay and
as soon as you got down here you're just
like freaking hitting shots
eating guacamole slamming it in your
face right
so how do you get from no to yes
just show up in cabo
it's a maybe
right how do you get somebody to say go
go from not selling their house to yes i
will
get to a maybe
and then follow them up at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable
well what i can share with you is you're
not alone that's number one and in most
cases
the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what more of the same results but
they are looking for different results
and so today i'm going to show you how
to break that pattern break that cycle
now you see
when you think of your results your
results are effects and so the question
is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits then
my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and i go well for what
she says well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth
and she said to me that she was a
caregiver and that she loved helping
families who needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year and so she really
didn't have enough money to be able to
take the care of her grandkids that she
wanted to to be able to take her
children on a vacation and so i shared
with her why do you think that you're
only earning twelve thousand dollars a
year and she said i don't know and when
i shared with her that she possibly
believed that that's what she was worth
and she said to me well i think i'm
worth more i said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level
of your brain
you have this feeling that maybe you're
not smart enough or not good enough or
not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do prior to
her coming to me and being in gratitude
was i helped her recognize that beliefs
drive behavior beliefs drive emotions
habits drive behavior and in order to
change your results living paycheck to
paycheck being stressed out worrying
about your future even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel
more confident more certain and more
empowered and what i can share with you
is she at that moment told me that she
went from making twelve thousand dollars
a year as a widow's from a widow's
pension and living paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
and she was making 75 000
a year you know i've been with you for a
long way i i the one moment that stands
out out of we've done i don't know how
many done we've done what 800 events the
one time was 4 a.m
we went out to practice at 4 00 a.m
and that was your idea to do it but and
then you know all these nike people are
like no no no no let's not let's not do
that and then you're like let's do it at
4 00 a.m so you got security you got
brand marketing sports marketing going
no no no no no no let's not do it you're
like let's do it because that's your
assessment right i mean to me it just
makes complete sense not to us but i
don't like
okay so see we all right
usually i'm sleeping at 4am
you're working out so talk about that
okay so if if
if your job is to try to be the best
basketball player you can be right
to do that you have to practice you have
to train right you want to train as much
as you can as often as you can
so if you get up at 10 in the morning
train at 11
right 12 say 12 train at 12 train for
two hours 12 to two um you have to let
your body recover so you eat recover
whatever you get back out you train
start training again at six
train from six to eight
right and now you go home you shower you
eat dinner you go to bed you wake up you
do it again right those are two sessions
right now imagine you wake up at three
you train at four go four to six come
home breakfast relax
now you're back at it again
nine to eleven
right you relax and now all of a sudden
you're back at it again two to four
and now you're back at it again you know
seven to nine
look how much more training i have done
by simply starting at four
right so now you do that and as the
years go on
the separation that you have with your
competitors and your peers just grows
larger and larger and larger and larger
and larger and by year five or six
doesn't matter
what kind of work they do in the summer
they're never going to catch up
because they're five years behind
right so it makes sense to get up and
start your day early because you can get
more work in is that genetic or is that
something you you ingrained and trained
yourself no it really taught you that
for me it was it was just common sense
like i can i can if i start earlier i
can train more hours and i know the
other guys aren't doing it because i
know what their training schedule is
right so i know if i do this
consistently over time
this the gap's just going to widen and
why and why and why and why and they
won't be able to get that back
so it to me it was just common sense i'm
like thinking how can i get an advantage
oh start earlier yeah let's do that when
did you start doing that
man
high school
high school we started my first class in
high school was seven
at 7 45 i used to get to the gym around
5 a.m
and i'd play before school and then
school will start playing with you at
5am my coach so my coach would show up
and we do all these basketball drills
right so just you and your coach just me
and my coach and sometimes it would just
be me and the janitor and who's still
there today and
um and um and then i play at lunch i
should get a medal
i i hooked him up with a few things
um
but i played during lunch and and then
practice after and then
you know go home do my schoolwork and
then watch a bunch of game film and
games on tv and
study
study film how do you develop that or
where do you what do you learn that from
well i think it's just you know it's
just a matter of what's important to you
and what's important to you for for
whatever reason
you know i i felt like um
i didn't feel good about myself if i
wasn't
doing everything i could to be the best
version of myself
if i felt like i left anything on the
table um it would eat away at me i
wouldn't be able to look myself in the
mirror
right so the reason why i can retire now
and be completely comfortable about it
because i know that i've done everything
i could to be the best basketball player
i could be
and so
that's where it comes from for me you
can't leave any stone unturned where i
got my work ethic from
was the hours i had to spend learning
this
when you sit down and you're not smart
you have a disability yeah
and you still want to be at the top of
your class i didn't want to get by
when i realized that i can learn through
hard work
and i can beat the valedictorian in
school but i got put in 10 hours more a
day than he does you know what kind of
strength comes from that
when you're sitting down that guy that
that valedictorian study for an hour and
you know i caught you
i caught you and i am dumb but i have
the work ethic to catch you that's where
david gaga's got really invented yeah
was at a kitchen table
with 20 spiral notebooks that were empty
and then three months later
yeah they were full
and when you can go through that i still
have them in my storage unit you're
going through these spiral notebooks of
your life
and you're like this is how i learned
this is unbelievable there's no miles
it's not about the miles it's that
having a discipline every day to say for
me to learn this one math problem
it's gonna take me 10 hours wow
and that's where it and you realize
through hard work
you can do you can out work anybody
remember how badass they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into because you made it this far
in a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
best motivational speeches of the year
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there but if you wake
up
and you start realizing i'm living in a
home an emotional home i don't want you
can change it
see because everybody's got if you got a
billion dollars check this out
if you had a billion dollars